the critical thing was because of
current market issues we realized we
have to do it in a different way it was
the market that did this it was the
market verdict on her mini budget
quasi-quarters mini budget that has
precipitated this enormous set of
u-turns because that market reaction has
then led to higher interest rates uh for
many households around the country not
to mention the bank of England having to
intervene well as a result of that it is
worth just taking a look and working out
what the market how the market has
reacted given that if she wasn't going
to get a good reaction well there's big
question marks over her future for a lot
of people is Beth was saying just then
for a lot of people particularly those
in the party but elsewhere as well her
future was hanging at stake here and
really it depended on how the market
viewed it well let's have a look at the
bond markets this in a way is the
epicenter of the story recently and what
I want to just show you quickly is the
30-year bond yield now this is a
complicated chart but all it's showing
you is the higher that this is the
higher the interest rate on this
long-term government debt is and broadly
speaking the government wanted to see it
go down so the lower that goes the
happier they are because that means
lower interest rates for everyone else
as I say complicated all sorts of stuff
going on but that's the main thing to
remember and look it was going down it
was going down from about Wednesday
afternoon into Thursday when those
stories came just yesterday about there
being a U-turn likely then you had the
moment overnight last night where
quasi-quarting returned from Washington
DC look at that line going down down
but here's the thing it started to rise
recently and look after the speech and
the press conference from Liz trust not
many questions of course look at what
happens to that line it's creeping up
again that I can tell you behind you in
Downing Street is something they are
going to be very very nervous about
because that is one of the lines and
there are a few different bond yields
you've got you know 30 years here that
that's in you know something people are
focusing on at the moment because that's
the one that the bank of England's
concerned about with what was going uh
with what's going on with Pension funds
right now but when those lines are going
up that means there is more pressure in
these markets and interest rates on
mortgages might well start to go up uh
as well so the fact that is reacting and
going in the wrong direction as far as
Liz cross is concerned is going to be a
concern but as you can see it's early
days you know that line is only kind of
a few minutes away from that speech but
so far I'm afraid so bad for Liz
trusting she hasn't got them up reaction
that she might have hoped for we'll have
to see what happens in the next few
minutes this has been a period where you
just have to look minute by minute at
how those markets are doing how they're
reacting to what the chancellor and
indeed the prime minister is saying and
their verdict will have enormous
consequences because well as we just
learned from the Prime Minister that was
basically what changed everything what
means that we're now potentially facing
a massively different economic climate
with a government that is Raising
corporation tax is cutting spending you
know that was one of the things that
that could have buried away there in
there that we are going to see
potentially more austerity we're not
hearing the Prime Minister saying
they're going to be no spending cuts she
said there will be spending cuts or
signals it's only in real terms there
will be these are enormous changes
enormous shifts but as I say right now
markets not looking enormously convinced
but it's early days so let's just see
how they go